28 was the number and where is JW b JW b
is right here challenge five standard
invite coming up game one of how many I
don't know okay
let's roll
why not let's kick off with Sicilian
night or f-- yes
coming up a six denotes that and now
what okay so I'm not sure how much of
this I really know I know the bishop
belongs here because this is week D five
take a good care over the d5 square
that's the plan and this night wants to
be in a spot to watch this guy I'm gonna
go with this
stop this g4 idea and let's see how
white responds to that hmm I might not
want to Castle kingside anytime soon
there's sometimes a purpose in just
leaving this rookie on the h-file if
white eventually gets in this g4 idea
there is a capture and then the rook
might have some some play with like a
rook up and over but okay this is uh
this is different what's going on with
that okay well what are you do in the
meantime
rook c8 Queen c7 or b5 those are the
three candidate moves that jump to mind
if there's a fourth it's this guy and
maybe of those four this is the best you
know why because it's his only move so
that's probably no surprise to team
white correct follow that important idea
mmm rook c8 Queen c7 b5 the night when
it plays here what am I gonna do and
well let's see let's see about things
here I don't know if there's a actually
of the of the of rook c8 in Queen c7 I'm
more inclined to move my rook first
maybe my queen can come out here at some
point I'm not sure what about b5 Knight
b6 that's actually an idea isn't it
b5 b6 yeah actually I'm not gonna move
rook b8 because I'm seeing actually some
variations where if my knight gets to c4
and is captured I can recapture it the
pond and then maybe play rook b8 and
target the b2 point so I think there's
some purpose and running forward with
the b5 move instead of declaring my
rooks intentions just yet maybe the C
file maybe the B file maybe I'll wait to
see what white does in response to maybe
a night landing right here
c4 the probably the weakest point
currently on white side of the board of
the ranks 1 through 4 this one right
here it's near the King a knight there
is very annoying the King will most
likely find it to be more comfortable on
b1 and if it's on b1 and my nights on c4
the knight is within checking distance
from D to a 3 possibilities for some
moves would without a doubt be present
and now I think that that can actually
turn out to be a waste of time because I
don't know that you could really
tolerate a knight on c4 so Knight b6 my
queen is currently constrained to the
defense of the night so I already know
the answer to this but something that I
do really quick is just make certain my
queen
not be deflected away from the defense
of the night I'm not seeing that really
as being a possibility so it's going to
be okay in other words and okay clearly
we're just white is prepping this move
right here I think there's something to
bid off when you see a move like that
taking a rook off of a functioning
excuse me a half open file if anything
this rook I think would have been better
and so now I think I can follow through
with this idea of Knight c4 after the
capture I recapture hit the night and
then maybe target this pawn another idea
is to just say you know what let's play
in the center let's open things up
because I think I'm gonna be in a better
position or will I push Bishop takes
Queen takes pawn takes guess what I
don't have enough defense for it so
maybe I should abandon that idea or is
there something with actually before
kicking that night away and only then
pawn push I'm gonna look into that one
let's see interesting possibilities here
Knight c4 and b4 and I guess maybe a
rugby eight move that seems a bit too
slow though
it's too slow although I'm gonna try
this one if the knight really wants to
take up an outpost on d5 this bishop has
to say so long okay now I think d5 it
can be played successfully push
let's give it a go I'm trying to open up
the position at a moment where I think
my pieces are better positioned this
night on the edge this night now has the
c5 Square available but maybe not for so
long if I could get d4 in fact this is a
serious problem I don't know that you
could really tolerate a pond on d5 with
you know threatening to play here
I am also watching over b4 even if I
wasn't and it could be grabbed it's not
without its problems because it does
open up files towards that white King
you'll want to be very cautious about
pawn grabbing if your castle and
opposite wings and that's exactly what
we have here well I'm not Castle just
yet but I'm not going to be castling
queenside not in my right mind at least
so what what are whites can it moves out
I'm thinking that Bishop takes Knight or
pawn captures right away I think this
guy is going to end up having to leave
soon I'm gonna go with this one
III don't really want to spend too much
time there were many different
possibilities there all right not the
Queen actually because I would just hang
my knight but I'm not sure which of
these two knights is best maybe it was
better for this night so that I can have
a knight a5 move available we're gonna
see though as a pretty smooth follow up
ideas I think something like a5 a4 comes
with great effect and this this is gonna
lead to trouble isn't it we're gonna
have an in-betweener
and I takes bishop oh and any between I
okay well trade Queens interesting I
think I want to trade Queens and then uh
could I
just take this then there's gonna be a
night fork no let's not and say we did
to that one king takes is no good
because of this so less than a minute
for our white interesting game so far
let me put pressure on this night my
bishop would really like to do something
other than sit on e7 at this point and
there is absolutely no need to castle in
a position like this King side castle
does not even enter my top process came
to e7 is going to be perfect so let's do
it
keep it Center it's on a dark square
opposite this Bishop and know what let's
see oh this is gonna be a problem I
think I take and then I play here I'm
not mistaken it that Bishop might be an
in-betweener here but there's no time to
figure this all out tough to play
accurately if the bishop plays here I
give a check and then there's this
deflection rook here is just trying to
be sneaky with Bishop takes and that
rook takes Bishop I might do that in the
bullet game or something just to make a
quick threat so there's also just rook
check in the night here I think that
seems pretty good actually that might be
that's actually netting material or the
bishop has to take that's the that's the
trick okay that's uh that's losing some
stuff here I actually have Knight check
or just Knight takes Knight if I give a
check and then maybe get the rook here I
don't need to do that calculation though
just play fast that's the plan play here
that pond is gonna go I get the pig on
the one Pig on the second and let's put
a bishop and time pressure gets the best
of anybody
okay where are the time burners okay
look up and overs or checks
one Pig matin - all right
the typical mouse race towards the end
all right good game let's back up let's
see
interesting middle game let's see how we
could make some improvements here either
one of us Naya daur Sicilian age 5 I
think I posted a video on my youtube
channel a while back out of this
variation where I did have black and I
think the game ended up in a draw so I
do provide a bit more insight with
regard to this age 5 idea I don't know
actually I think in that game h4 was was
played as well I didn't do the bests
against it but I am this Bishop e2 move
okay this is where let me back up I
think this right here is maybe a bit off
you could try to baby step it in the
following way like if you really want to
be getting in this g4 move you could be
running with and I'm not saying right
away but given the time you could be
going with the g3 H 3 and then g4 in
that order
you'll also need to take into account
that your rook is unprotected so you
know maybe maybe getting your Bishop out
but if you do want to get g4 in you'll
have to baby step it as otherwise h3 is
Matt with h4 and there's there's no way
to get in g4 successfully because I
always have that on croissant move so
you could consider that instead of this
particular PI move then you're not
having to and another way to look at it
is you won't be having to do what you
won't be having to devote a rook to this
G 1 squared just to facilitate upon
advance if you press forward in the
correct order with your own pawns your
rook is not needed for such a role
so you your castling Bishop e2 I think
this is just turning out to be way too
slow something seems way off with that
so I think looking into those types of
pawn advances could turn out to be
pretty good because if the H file is
going to open up then I really have to
do something quick doing that I have to
well I really don't want a castle and if
the H file opens up I'm having to make a
decision because you have a lead in
development your your fully developed at
this point rooks in direct contact with
one another so I think that's worth a
closer look or even another idea is to
maybe plant up on this d5 square at an
earlier point but look into this
different g3 h3 g4 idea you'll need to
be castled and have your Bishop on e2 or
in other words your rook on h1 needs to
be protected before you actually follow
through with that g4 advance it's
another another angle another way to
look at it another approach another plan